今天量人急動不到1000不到1兆
不到9000億不到8000億
怎麼會這樣量人急動
台股不行了嗎?
下週要變盤嗎?
這是今天關盤重點
今天我們節目重點之一
第二個美債飆破40兆
前幾年還不到30兆
現在飆破40兆美金
台股是不是經燥?
債務會不會引爆股災?
這個很重要
第三個 哇 主動型ETF很多開始賣國具了
被動元件完了嗎
連日本的春田製作所股價看起來要打跌這角
國具還要再破500元嗎
那其他被動元件不就死定了嗎
今天所有的標股介紹還有大盤的行情
我一次講個夠
今天台股開低走高最後漲了290點
收漲在425224點
投資朋友們都有發現到
台股量能明顯萎縮
加上昨晚美股很震盪
大家都很好奇主要原因到底是什麼呢
話說回來投資長的股票還是表現不錯
投資長的群聯今天逆勢走強
又重新占回2000元大關啦
投資長的國劇今天在平盤附近震盪
隨時準備要發動啦
有些投資朋友很擔心0098EA賣股
但你想知道投資長是怎麼看的嗎
你還沒上車
手上還沒有標股嗎
接下來就交給我們經濟日報
選股冠軍單計188%的紀錄保持者
同時也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
最受歡迎的分析器
郭哲榮投資長
投資長好
莉莉各位大家好
哇今天台灣股市
亮梭
是怎麼辦
亮梭就很難股票
很難噴出去,真的
所以今天看到根本今天長金融股
長一些CPO,長到航運股
腰膜軌跡都出來了
航運股不算腰膜軌跡
可是它跟AI沒有什麼扯上什麼關係
所以怎麼會這樣子
你看量縮,你自己看大盆量縮
Ganne啦
是不是7100億,是不是7192億
你看是不是近期新低
反彈沒量產的啦
我今天量怎麼可以這麼縮
8000、3000、7000、1000
這個7000不成比例
這個有問題
量一直在縮
怎麼那麼慘
怎麼辦
這個有點問題
沒關係大概這邊
量一直在縮
這麼低的量縮
今天還有8000多
昨天還有8000多
還有1兆的
現在變7000億的
前陣子這邊的時候
1.5兆,這碗左一點有1.5兆以上
是不是
怎麼會差這麼多
現在變0.7兆了
是
台股是不是金兆
是不是,怎麼會這樣子呢
戀說真的很難出標股
只會出那一種,有人說無戀出標股
能夠出那種單一主力的那種標股
拱不上去散步很麻煩
我又不是說我看到串劍大漲
我就跟你講
我今天有串劍
我今天旺海 牙名漲 旺海漲 我就跟你講我有航運股
不是這樣啦 不是說股票有漲
我做事都是我的 我不做這種事
老頭顧的事情我不做 這樣也會出事我不喜歡
我會做你是不是為了出事我不喜歡講這種好話
所以我告訴大家怎麼辦
我在這邊要怎麼辦的時候 我們先來一首歌好不好
這是符合我們的歌詞 好不好
好不好 站我歌
有沒有聽過那個說說說說你愛我
是不是大舌頭是不是
那台股也是說啊 說到不行嘛
從說到不行到怎麼樣
到滿手套牢
到冷過低潮轉野股價串心高
讓你衝衝衝 轉轉轉
從這邊我們開始
小哈 瑞迪好了嗎
我們瑞迪 插吧
說說說說說到不行
慢慢慢慢慢慢收套牢
忍忍忍忍忍過低潮
一轉眼骨架穿新高
衝衝衝衝衝破千高
包包包包包勁包勞
轉轉轉轉轉到發飆
這一波才不翻白白
喔不錯
小安妮應該站在另外一邊
真的不錯我們知道
說說說說到不行
慢慢滿手套牢
很多人像被那人念套牢
忍忍忍忍過低潮
一轉眼骨架穿新高
你要冷過才會衝衝衝衝衝破錢高
爆爆爆 報警報勞
賺到發飆這一波財富翻百倍
你翻百倍那很誇張
那麽翻倍就開心了好不好
股市沒有一定
但如果就是我預期的一個十萬點
我講不清了
我講的是5年內甚至4年內
甚至可能更快
我跟大家講可能更快
我明天跟人家開玩笑
你要去了解AI
比如昨天有說Moderna
這MRNA的疫苗
同學你要去了解這些邏輯
那時候接下來台灣股市怎麼走
我們先慢慢講那些總經鏈好不好
好
因為總經鏈很多可以講
等一下
看一下台灣股市的走勢度
先看台美股市
有沒有
廢半了
最近納斯拉克打第二隻腳
可是就好像講的
納斯拉克今年大概漲12%左右
所以他沒有理由再一次破敵
AEI還是無鹽博界第二個
廢半今年好像漲了好像快60%
如果沒有記錯的話快60%
快60% 60%以上 神經病60%以上
拉回或怎麼辦
不用擔心台灣股市大革是廢半加納斯大革的指數平均漲幅
加起來處於2 這兩個最近開始也沒破底
可是他們也沒很強
台灣股市看起來我一下晚上一副晚上展的樣子
台灣股市已經偷笑
可是台灣股市現在散戶該進來的都進來
該套牢都套牢了
大家可以看被動員警制
所以最大問題是美國股市也要死不活
美國股市要受到美國公債的影響
昨天不是說美國公債有機會
可是有機會也不會這麼快就解決了
因為畢竟債務越滑越大
像滾水球般
美工在直率又再度彈升,所以你把它壓下來嘛
我說很簡單,2007年跟現在
這是美在直率有沒有,這是30年期美在直率這個
這是美在直率,這是費的利率有沒有
有
這費的利率好,所以美在直率2007年戳破泡沫
不是美在直率戳破泡沫
2007年是費的利率戳破泡沫
你看現在美在直率是5.31
然後呢,5.31,可費得率3.63,有沒有看到?
他們差很大,以前差不了多少
那其實美在直率怎麼低,基本上不會低於費得率
這很簡單,為什麼?
我美在直率我低於費得率,我去存定存就好
我買什麼美在?對不對?沒錯吧?
所以美在直率5.31,可是現在費得率3.63
定存利益都是以這個為主的
至少有操作空間
所以曾經打壓他去買美債
買30年期美債
賣出比較短的10年期的美債
這個先不要叫他價太多
買美債 美債價格就往上了
資率就往下滑
打下去了 打下去以後結果今天又拉起來了
大家覺得真的假的
不要擔心 美國財政部長他是非常優秀的
他是那個 你索羅斯的徒弟
不是索羅斯 他真的也叫索羅斯
翻譯翻譯
華爾街那麼老 華爾街那個民私出高徒
所以索羅斯的徒弟他是真的華爾街
所以他在很靈活的 我覺得還是有機會
你看像美國現在以前在講
哇!一年兩千萬噸的石油
應該現在早就有問題
你看美國反而沒問題
美國反而賺寶寶
好不好?很奇怪
荷姆之海蝦不是被封鎖嗎?
油價怎麼沒有到140
連100都沒有
所以這都是他們的節奏很厲害
操縱金融行情
他們要不要做而已
好不好?這跟大家講
就是現在要死不活
可是我昨天要跟大家講
我說我古災記起來
很多人說股災通常爆發
爆發的時候通常最晚的時候
頂多到9月是差不多了
現在8、9月差不多了
之前有人那時候留言說
哲哲你講錯了
你講說2022年的時候
2022年我歡迎來挑戰我
我不能說這個我只是印象而已
2022年的時候股災在10月份
沒有你們看一下
在2022年對不對
2022年是一整年都鼓摘好不好
我說沒錯吧 這10月份
10月份這邊有沒有
10月25號 12629
這10月份
10月份這邊有沒有對不對
對
它從3月2月開始
從1月5號開始有沒有
一整年 一直跌
就是升息含情
所以我最怕台灣股市一直升息
因為資金會被抽走
那美在直流一直漲 也不行
因為資金會被抽走,股市就怕沒有資金,對不對
所以那一整年你不能說第一點見到10月
就是10月是股災沒有
我講的是通常那種爆發性的股災
你看關稅,319槍擊案很多的事情
關稅是不是2016年那時候好像也有2016年17年
中美貿易戰那時候有9月10月
可是我要告訴你,如果景氣循環
所造成的那種比如五穹六角七扇掉
其實頂多到八九月就結束了
但怎麼到 大部分要走空 精氣的衰退
九月之前就會結束 不會說 哇
九月才突然發生
那當然第一點有的時候是十月
有時候是十一月 金融海嘯是十一月
那不一樣喔 因為它可能五月發生
你得到10月是有這樣子的喔
是
5月發生
然後得到11月
這是有的
可是不通常不會
9月10月才給你爆發一個金融海嘯
要怎麼知道
警器的海嘯
懂嗎
OK嗎
那最近難什麼
來
為什麼陽明廠
我告訴大家為什麼陽明廠
我也認為現在不要追陽明
不要追萬海
既然中石屋大陸就是做一波道
你去問所有的業界人都知道
真的很厲害,好懂Moderna,好懂疫苗,好懂黨務存也好,好懂AI也好
連這個東西都要知道,所有的這個
因為我是航運王,你知道嗎?
我是777出趙子龍,航運國,有沒有印象?
來,這航運國,所有人都知道,9月、8月的時候是萬計
是
8月底,絕對通常都有出貨潮
要專貨、運貨,要送到美國去
你說到美國去 你美國去萬聖節
萬聖節11月是不是
因為你在美國讀書
萬聖節10月底
10月底啊 沒錯啊
差不多的
10月底我送床
也就是送一送二
要連一兩個月
還落到二型
所以我8月就要送啊
所以9月底這個萬計就不見了
因為我萬聖節就要送
我一年穿成季節
萬聖節 所以是10月底
我也是10月初
10月底
對
你看
你也有去美國讀個書
10月底你8月就要裝戶了兩個月
所以你10月 萬聖節一送
還有聖誕節嘛 是不是
還有港恩節 對不對
是港恩節什麼時候
港恩節是11月
11月嘛 第幾個星期五是不是 忘記了
還是那是港恩節的那個銷售忘記
不是
萬聖節 港恩節 聖誕節 10月 11月 12月
還會一起鋪貨
所以8月就會怎麼樣
就會運送的高潮
你們不要想歪了
我是說送貨的高潮
好像運股會拉起來
所以你看到
陽明站拉百分之二
資本車
陽明站拉
然後呢
長龍也這樣拉
我講陽明長龍汪海
不是在你去買
而是告訴你景氣的衰退
通常不會9月以後
因為怎麼樣都會好
因為怎麼樣你都會購物
萬聖節景氣不好
你更會送禮物
多少會送禮物
但能不能 我要強調 我跟你講的
現在買很safe啦 現在買很安全 懂不懂
你看還運過就知道 送資料到萬聖節
港恩節 聖誕節
是不是 這名字都取得好聽
那什麼親民姐妹 都親民出事情
我說台灣啦 開玩笑
來自三個節
所以你八月就要送 你那個運送
你買車子就知道啦
有時候送過來運送
兩個月三個月都要有時候走海路的話
走會貴的話一個月兩個月很正常
所以現在就要開始要送貨
還要送貨到以後還要包貨
還要專載還要到三貴
到貨品貴都要時間的
所以下半年通常經濟經濟
怎麼樣都不會太差
這是會讀書的人不會給你講真心
會做股票的人一定知道
沒有人 尤其沒有人會在12月做空
好不好 OK嗎
基本上沒有人會在12月做空
好不好 大家不要想不開 OK嗎
越到年底 越容易做多 越該做多
所以從航運股告訴你
今年至少大家也準備了怎麼樣
聖誕節的景氣 萬聖節的景氣
所以在這邊貨櫃有人說是先行指標
代表景氣到年底一樣
又再來一次了不會太差
你要看貨櫃股什麼時候還展增的
如果9月底9月30號 9月25號差不多了
9月底運價還能上去
不是看股價運價還能上去
那可能展增的那就萬一整年
可是基本上不會上去的好不好
OK嗎
所以這波大波大乎才會拉那麼緊
從貨櫃的走勢告訴你
年底更應該做多
因為忘記又來了 忘記又來了
真的不知道
來來
兩個門要看一下
我們來看一下大家有沒有什麼問題
來 環球金很好啊
八一百環球金太多賞入了
環球金賞入不多
環球金有時候是看我的節目
其中學警怎麼樣
做等揮打法會下禮拜四
對不對
12月美國人業讓價錢只會做空
只會放空 腦袋放空
但股票不會做空
因為到最後會口袋空空
知不知道
OK嗎
來來
買美債安心
沒有沒有現在美債不要
每載只有一個人悲傷的世界
台股量縮會下跌
量縮應該這樣講
量縮沒辦法撐住大盤
沒辦法讓大盤突破四萬八
量縮就像這種
你們有交過比說哇股市也是一樣
我們看一下
量縮像三角首領
我們舉個慘龍意義好不好
三角收斂到極致有沒有看到
有沒有
這三角收斂到極致就會噴出去
就戀岸說到極致的時候就像三角收斂到極致
要不要噴出去要不要往下這樣有沒有懂
OK嗎
都不好意思問我們了吧
所以戀岸說只是告訴你要決勝負
神奇寶貝我們要決勝負的時候
大家會留言說責責寶貝
別別別別
可是你有沒有看到大家很現實
最近骨盆沒上來
沒上來的大家就比較少稱我寶貝了
好像是欸
你們都很現實 都是復興漢
你們讀復興中學的嗎
還是捷運復興戰
東校復興戰
都是渣男
開玩笑的喔 都渣男
他說的不是我說的喔
沒有女生說比較沒問題 男生說不行
好不好 來來
這寶貝絕世人夫 來來
貨櫃為什麼長
來來
則技術分析簡單二要五千八百人
謝謝大家
來 莊美金怎麼辦
我們先講好啊 莊美金怎麼辦
我們先講籌碼好了
有好多人用莊美金跟環球金
我們先講莊美金環球金
再講國具好了
來喔 這個我覺得國在之利率
每一支利率還是可以下滑一點點
沒有那麼慘
來
莊美金環球金 先講莊美金好了
最近有新聞,AVF講料裝美金贏轉單對不對?
這是利多嘛對不對?
是
給我開高走低
怎麼問這樣
現在股市這大戶玩股票就是我倆沒有明天
我們沒有明天,你錄完就走了啦
就走啦
買完就走了啦
這個很扯
那這個什麼新聞我們看一下
來看一下
我們來看一下這個新聞
ABI那個AI晶片的帶動槽有沒有
ABI晶片不是需求爆發嗎
ABI載板需求急增
2023年就急增了
ABI載一整張
剛開始長
我印象很深刻
那時候我ABU載板轉翻了
然後我在去年前年底去年的時候
買ABU載板 買新星
100多元抵押7、80元被人家罵的
好像混蛋一樣 現在都找1000多元
那些罵我的被那些其他分析手勇的
怎麼辦
最大問題是那些分析師
不要再每天扯一頁的話
反正記得一件事
會攻擊分析師的分析師
大部分是業績差
業績好哪有時間供給人家
我一定會講沒錯吧
沒錯
沒有那種什麼你機價很好業績很差
沒有這回事的
機價真的很好
序都序不完的
對不對
沒錯
那個接口鄰居都會把你介紹了
就是業績不好
好不好
就這樣子
所以不要去像看那種會供給分析
會供給分析師的分析師
記得這樣
好啦那扯遠了
那ABU的載板真的我從七八十塊
一路轉到現在一千多塊
我好像三四百塊就走了
沒關係
沒有關係
我真的喜歡買
就留一點給人家賺
我這個人就留一點給人家賺
好啦 胃之素
聽起來好像是那種
胃圈的素 素精
胃精
胃精 對 胃精聽起來像胃精
胃精不錯
你休息得很年輕 今天不錯
今天街梗不錯
胃精啊 欸是不是像胃精
你看我已經要說我選擇進出貨策略
我要優先滿足日系
台灣產商接貨公減三成產的
我沒有巧負難為5米之吹
其實我實在是大約90%
精華科技
少數具備自主研發
你通過多數AI科物驗證明出貨
影轉單效率加速不取
這聽起來應該大力多
中美金反正控股集團
他旗下什麼環球金啊
施谷也不傻嗎
就跟開高走低
這新聞如果是對的話
其實中美經濟大力多
至少有題材
你有沒有給你漲
對EPS影響不多
可是有題材就會漲
莫名其妙
就是說
說
你挨握台股就說沒辦法
好不好
可是你看看越說
看我節目越嗨
說我們還是這麼多人去看我們節目
為什麼
因為我們是有兼具娛樂性
搞笑性跟專業性
專業最重要 起碼專業排第一
這個是真的利多啦 那利多
專門已經拉一拉一起拉個環球晶章
環球晶章沒有 機師怎麼會這樣
因為我跟妳講一件事 通常打第二支腳
我們看一下 聯盟同國劇都打第二支腳
拚了 我跟你講命一條 拚了
國劇真的有點太扯了 好不好
會不會破底 我看國劇有的看起來
我不知道會不會破底 我覺得破底機率很低
就算會破底也是假破底怎麼樣
到時候真穿頭我跟你講
你知道嗎
是
就是真的破人也沒關係 就病因了
因為怎麼樣都比1200人來得好好不好
破底以後說明那些1200人就會怎麼樣
大逃殺
全部砍掉砍掉我這邊的人我砍掉我砍掉砍掉
就會拉起來 那為什麼
懂
現在要洗清服額 來來
你看我今天做很多資料
越含情 我這個人就是很變態
越無聊的時候
我就會我反很多梗
含情越崩潰的時候反更越多信心
真的你多看
今天是不是很認真做資料來看一下
國劇我跟你講一下來
要求我這些人
國劇有沒有到
國劇股東的人數有沒有到
從多少
這國劇喔
從3幾20幾萬有沒有到
5月22號20幾萬有沒有到
到現在變50幾萬
對
太多人有了啦
以前一對沒聽過國劇啦
是不是 啊現在聽過國劇 樂劇什麼都聽過了
可能樂劇國劇你沒看幾個 可是股票國劇你有聽過
大家都聽過
大家聽過 對
大家不會知道你樂劇是什麼都不知道
算了 倒沒說過
戲劇的劇 這樣怎麼懂
好啦 不要再扯了
來 國劇每個人都聽過了
是不是 從20幾萬到50幾萬
看一下 太扯了 我用簡單的來給你講
這個做這個圖我沒有意義
我今天跟威漢講不能做這種圖
要做這種圖就OK有沒有看到
放大喔 本來22萬在這邊有沒有看到
有
5加629有沒有看到
威漢就做不多
恭喜大家考上分析師
明年這時候他應該就當分析師
祝福他 所以你看我們訓練團隊
其實我們研究團隊都是分析師
台大、政大
都是這樣子的
好不好?快計師的都是這樣子的
都是非常非常厲害的
不然我們怎麼選出股票來?
選出那種標的標股
好不好?來
但你會選值得的最近股票不標
他說最近啊各位
不然就不是天天過年啊
你真的每次那麼厲害啊
我整個一買馬上展平反
還是你要等值得下次
我再掏一億的時候
這跟我買
要等一年啊
你要等嗎?
來
2020年5月22號有沒有看到股東22萬了
有沒有看到
有
股價629元有沒有看到
這邊一拉
從22萬變30萬有沒有看到
20萬變30萬就很多人恐怖
你知道嗎
是
那個要給我股價
這邊股價有
這邊從620元到850有沒有看到
股東增加10萬
很扯13萬
然後咧
然後再從怎麼樣
再從855元噴到
股東怎麼樣?
增加到39萬噴到
有
最快的是這邊有沒有噴到
600到800元噴到
這邊股東的數字增加很多
所以我們可以重新說
我也不認真了
難怪這一波跌到670幾元
看你殺下來
因為最多就這一塊嘛
從622到855元
有沒有增加13萬人有沒有噴到
是
是不是
那這一波不是談到670幾元嗎
是
就殺下來
你看 因為這波 因為增加600多到800是增加人數最多
13萬人
很多人 我解套了我趕快走了
差不多我套牢了 小培了我走了
到這邊1220元這附近的時候 39萬人還好
可你看喔 殺到 39萬人你看到喔
再殺下去的時候
怎麼樣?這一波殺下去,股東人數從39萬變50萬,又增加
聽懂嗎? 懂
現在唯一的好處是怎麼樣?人總算減少3000人,0.3萬人
所以很恐怖的是我們來給你總結,來看一下
你看我們做的圖很漂亮
大概啦,700元以上我要跟著你
700元以上可能就有點壓力了
快700元有沒有
這邊接近700元以上有沒有
是不是
是
股東人數從22萬 22.5萬
到多少
大概差不多到54萬
成不成
好誇張喔
32萬的服裝籌碼在這邊通一通被套了
難怪講國劇那麼多
多32萬人欸
兄弟們站起來
我成本很低,不用怕,拉回來買
他們受不了,所以這個洗清服務要一段時間
Model,Model,Modell,在第二個還有什麼原因?
來,萬事具備指千龍風,他現在萬事都不具備
你要等誰?川田製作所,請你要怎麼樣?
川田製作所,相關的全部要納入考量
來看一下
但是咧
怎麼沒有春田製作
春田製作
這次要求很嚴厲
現在我會念一下威漢
不過沒差,那是現在念他
等他當分析的時候
我就決口不提他
我是這種人
因為沒什麼好提的
就是我會注武他
也不算就是沒什麼好提示說
我不要讓大家覺得單分醫師就支持他
我不會讓大家覺得說
哇他還是菜鳥你知道嗎
把他講成像菜鳥不喜歡
但是因為他現在還沒有
雖然考上分機師
但是還沒有正式的就是開始遭受會員
因為他要訓練一陣子
我們莫這樣
我們莫單分醫師這樣子
有些人是單分醫師
也會投過單分醫師
看你帥你去單分醫師
OK嗎
我們沒有
我們是一定要經過訓練的
騷折兩年
衛翰來這邊已經快一年的時間了
來
春天製作所來看一下
比他頭光模仿也沒有用
因為我親自教的這個模仿
是
對不對
春天製作所你看
為什麼我練武衣漢
你看一下做分析師
你看門道
你不要看我們模分析師的特別強
我開始說
我開始說做治安圖對不對
是不是
治安圖對不對
不夠明顯因為字很小
我現在做清楚一點
就要給我做清楚以後
怎麼樣 我回去會念他
你知道怎麼回去念他嗎
請問你在看出來什麼ABC一波嗎
看了出來股價從高沙下來嗎
所以我一看做這張圖很不行
所以你們看同樣是分析師
同樣在做圖就差很多了
要解這個
你不覺得這張解釋這一張走勢圖
比較像國劇的走勢圖嗎
真的耶
你看我一看做這一張圖
就完全不像國劇的走勢圖
你看我一看你對他多好
浪費我全部時間
大家一萬多人聽怎麼當分析師
所以你不要看我是很變態
我是非常管教非常演的
你看這怎麼看得出來
跟國際有像
他也不動腦輪怎麼辦
是不是
自然看起來跟國際有像
對不對
你看一下就知道是不是
所以陳鐵之路跟國際有像
紫澤有點像
歪軸再拉長一點就可以了
好不好
歪軸就是把它拉長一點
比例把它拉長一點
是不是又有點像是不是
沒錯吧
拉長一點,三十月像,四十月像國際對不對
所以春田製作所圖很重要
春田製作所股價看起來要打第二支橋
好恐怖喔,你不要怕,就是我回到我的重點
我就直覺告訴你了,我青年來告訴你了
我說沒有人在下半年,尤其十二月做孔
股災通常是九月之前
那你說有些是沒辦法如果你來個地震
來個打戰那個我們沒辦法預測
對
可是股災通常經濟的股災
經濟的股災通常9月之前就結束了
為什麼?
因為9月以後我要鋪貨
我只要EPA值多在前面
EPA值多漂亮啊
你懂不懂?
我要投資啊
懂不懂?
OK嗎?傳統萬計啊
這個給你補充一下
航運股的走勢看起來真的要鋪貨了
是不是?
是
EPA值多漂亮啊
是不是?
這跟人家講是這邊拉股你就做多你怕什麼
你會怎麼買一些電子產品吧?
變動員間有那麼差嗎?
本業有成吧是不是?
是
我要重點,你要跌到400元
你要記得一件,兄弟,康當一下好不好
他也才兩、三百元這樣漲而已
你要跌到300元
人家是這邊而已,你就知道跌破頭
人家跌多少啊?冷靜啊
現在衝馬很亂
我跟你講一件事
我看最好0098,通通賣觀光
我還包著它賣官官,我是認真的,你知道什麼?
它賣官官要上去1200,你不會覺得我是最厲害的
雖然我不需要給它比,它一個主動式ETF
不好意思,我就是霸氣,我告訴你,非動員先看好
但是有史以來說,記憶體還是很強
記憶體本益比那麼低,非動員件它獲利還沒那麼高
本益比很高,沒記憶體要比
誰叫你要比記憶體?我不需要比記憶體
我只要國際800元以上 要求不多啦
有機會籌碼亂 加上國外的被動元件
股價也下去 也打第二隻腳
就這兩個原因 沒用什麼原因好不好
怎麼樣 我最喜歡一部電影
《爛子彈飛一回》
OK嗎
講這東西比較政治 你也點頭 你想看那部電影
我有聽過
你有聽過 這部電影很好看
還不錯
跟對岸 跟什麼我喜歡 不是沒有
我什麼都看 我什麼歷史故事都看
爛子彈飛 這是扯遠的
這不是重點 爛子彈飛毀各位 OK嗎
籌碼亂那麼多人是不是 OK嗎
怎麼看台積電拉尾盤 股市拉起來
國際買到510 620沒賣掉
台慶科就跌回原點
那基本面差不多 霸氣則保
謝謝你 仔仔寶貝
來 黃宇晶洗我很久了好不好
昨天給我加貓看 他說他興奮到哈記
對啊 哈記 哈記是 哈記是開心嗎
應該是呼嚕呼嚕才是開心嗎
哈記好像貓咪哈記 你不是養貓嗎
哈記是有點兇的意思
對啊 你到底會養貓啊
怎麼會這樣
是啊 你看一下 川普爸爸
昨天給我家貓看哲哲 她興奮到哈氣
一看就知道你慘了 你根本就虐待貓
你根本不懂貓的開心
你看我還懂 我都有設略
我平時不好 她忽視忽如露
是不是 哈氣是她不高興 不耐煩
你這個叫明包暗扁我
昨天給我家貓看哲哲 她興奮到哈氣
你再表達不耐煩 好不好
不過貓的確是這樣子 你不能給她太大聲音
刺激她
對 貓的彈性
他有時候會刺激他你知道嗎
是
有些貓 你看有些人比如說有些貓
哇 那個會抓主人
都是你們自己發出尖銳的聲音你知道嗎
你突然發尖銳的聲音
他對聲音很敏感
其實貓會攻擊人家
或者洗澡的時候會攻擊人家
最重要是什麼樣的
他是受到刺激
他其實他膽子很小
可是膽子很小
你越刺激他就會反擊
是這樣子的 重點是這樣子的
天涯的投資長真的什麼都知道
我什麼都懂
其實我很怕貓
因為我鼻子不好
我會過敏
會過敏 對啦 可是你什麼都知道
你看 都得了解是不是 是
什麼 因為你很貓是不是 有
是不是 你們要解貓就知道了
講話不要那麼大聲 好不好 來 成遠了
請問 男生你們男生記得一件事
如果要怎麼樣 要追女生知不知道
都得了解貓 你知道嗎
還有共通話題 我真的不是因為這個原因
直播破裂全人的還好啦
這就是實際上全人 謝謝大家
經濟怎麼看 經濟觀看人數不少
攔下列車來接人喔
來來
邏輯最強的帥子請問緊述
剛才不是說ABU的載板
ABU的缺料怎麼好
缺料怎麼好
所以這貼連點 貼缺料不好啦
OK嗎
ABU的載板缺料不好 是不是
但是他是搶中
他是把中國的ABU的載板不理他
你懂我意思嗎
剛才那個未知數
胃脂素叫做胃精
把他記成胃精就好
今天外資買超280.3億
其實外資買得很兇
買280.3億
還不錯
算強的
因為轉成美國股市
我記得沒錯斬跌互見
是不是
沒有理由
我說這個怪怪的
廢半跟那
其實我覺得這個很特別
感覺外資買盤回來了
是不是
像台幣多少?
31.8嘛
錢只要32.3
你看單分音是要懂很多數字
怪怪的
因為基本上這個納斯拉克點那麼兇
費半傻那麼少
基本上今天不會是買鈔
所以今天外資可能開始
可能因為有個部分是因為
他覺得美債不值錢
我講美債是垃圾也可以上新聞
再講一次 美債就是垃圾
我就買最多垃圾的男人
不會我愛你們
記著一件事
1.71美債就是我買了,買了又放著等賺2000幫他再走
誰叫我有這個諾言
稻窮費辦
來看一下,費辦跟納斯拉克
所以今天外資買超聯盟都也很特別
很少會這樣子買,記著這樣子
中美金投信來乾健倉,我覺得是跌假的
我看中美金,我看一下中美金
其實以前中美金蠻喜歡的
我的股票你知道新興那時候70幾塊的時候
根本沒人理我
我看很遠的啦
77元我真的覺得接下來會缺貨
真的耶 你們會看耶
對喔 你看喔
你滿厲害的喔
我們看到周邊金門道
之前278元買到 一堆買7000多張
那時候累積量
多少
2,我們看一下,按到了,馬上按一下給大家聽
你看到278元有沒有看到,然後買個1萬多站不到
那時候乘車,那時候累積量27萬元到
看不太到沒關係,我再跟你們講
好,後來有刪下去,因為量有減少,是外資減
投信其實投信有些人賣掉了
買了11000張這邊陸續賣掉
你講的沒錯 這不錯 這連三日買
這應該有主動型一貼服
你們查一下 我到時候我也查一下
這應該有主動型一貼服的認養它
可以放大嗎?
對 它剛太小
之前沒有放大對不對?
投信對不對?
對
最近買的應該有一兩檔主動型一貼服的認養
這蠻特別的
那中本金上去,換金金不會上去
我跟你講,你看換金金投資人在買
我居然在認養,怪怪的
我的節目你覺得沒有人會看
很多金金人是我信徒,只要他們不會承認
沒有關係,我都祝福你們
只要講話有時候很討厭,節目效果你們不要緊張
要是金母也是一樣,你要不要買,你要不要賣
各做各的沒有關係
我都愛你們,來啦
一提公我的股票也沒關係
有在買
你們認真
其實現在投信的規模有變小一點點
你知道什麼嗎
規模變大兩種
一種是我錢投進去
一種是我的錢變大
比如說我股票從1000塊漲到2000塊
我規模是應該要變一倍
如果股票都變一倍的話
像規模說剪的
因為股票就沒漲
這已經沒漲
存定額有進去也不會那麼快
所以他買現在還有錢的
買環球金鐘門已經要注意一下
你看我們在Sense很多
你看我已經看很多東西
可是他玩友
哲哲這個方面怎麼看
我們被人聯好的互動有沒有看到
哲哲寶貝舊舊性餐店
星期五直播人數會打折
有人請假出去玩
最近蠻多的
來來
7000多人
今天7000個禮拜我算很多的
按這個帳好不好
按一次讚就好,按兩次讚會減少好不好
指責保衛資源來跟大家講好不好
外資最樂勝
信餐店
來來
我服了來來我們跟大家講
華興跟國具一樣
華興科我想買了
華興科哪一天我買了你不要覺得奇怪
非洲元件我跟你講不一樣那麼差的
都未缺 AI都未缺 邊緣運算未缺
我從頭到尾 國劇1500
不理他 可是我國劇100個500元
有沒有機會到800到1000
也有機會 860%、1600%、成本不同決定的高度
成本不同決定高度 OK嗎
知道
這跟大家講 大家有沒有問題
來 管達前面買金還有G
很大這種股票就沒什麼
沒什麼不要想那麼多好不好
剛剛講到匯率的影響
匯率的升值
那我講一件事
你美債不值錢
有些人就不會買美債
甚至把美約
所以不買美債
你懂不懂
不買美債的人要怎麼辦
有些是國外資金
美債沒有意義
我就把美債賣掉怎麼樣
匯為台幣
匯為台灣
匯為台灣幹嘛
就買股票
你懂不懂
是
所以美債不值錢
很多人匯完美國是為了買美債
我美債我不想買啊
我現在是為你們關係演叫
我現在賣賠1000萬我也沒差
因為我很快台灣50賺回來啦
我是認真的
你們百分之百說沒問題
不要再買95%都沒問題
我一定馬上賣
明天賣我很開心
我不許我賠1000萬
我覺得我少賺1億
是真的
如果換成台灣50
所以很多人把美債
現在美債是不是
我看你講的
你看我的東西都一套的
直率很高
為什麼直率很高
因為很少人買美債
因為美債本來以前不知道差異照變40照
東西越來越不值錢
是
供給越來越多就東西不值錢
就是台灣醫生
如果我們台灣醫生像菲律賓醫生一樣
哇 我不設限
是不是 中國不設限
那台灣醫生薪水就會降低了
但台灣醫生很優秀
還有因為他們等等很聰明
可是如果人數變多
一樣薪水會打著
所以供給跟需求才是決定這個價格
每再供給那麼多
每再數量那麼多 價格下滑
價格下滑每再值於上升
你知道嗎
好
我剛才講每再值於是不是上升了
價格下環你就會賣這樣美債
賣這樣美債我乾脆我連美元都不要
我就換回台幣的好不好
所以對股市還是有點止沉你知道嗎
OK嗎
這跟大家講
來
有人洗一把
這一週取幾次健身房
大概一週
因為其實我不是臭屁
人家覺得我剛才很賺對不對
你們不要羨慕
我一週
因為最近比較累
不是因為年紀大了
不是你講年大好像太老
工作太忙了啦
我比較喜歡那個輕運動 跑步
有養比較重要
重訓 你們看到很多人肌肉量到老的時候
肌肉量太大 那是負荷
那練到很像撞得像星星反而都找死你知道嗎
真的喔
真的喔 因為你對你欣賞這種負荷
你看很多 你看管子能知道
你看他有以前撞嗎 沒有
到最後都是這樣子
他什麼魯尼還羅尼
就是有一個幾屆的健身冠軍
到最後都不良於行
所以剛好就好
剛好就好 所以我一個禮拜
大概一個禮拜大概健身一次
有時候兩周一次 我還是可以維持肌肉量
你不必羨慕我 我肌肉長很快
我天生肌肉長很快
好啦 可是這沒什麼需要的啦
你難道是因為看我肉體還喜歡我嗎
不會吧 不一定喔
可能有喔
你這樣子我很尷尬耶
你在喵哪裡
啊 不跟你開玩笑了啦
好啦 聽觀眾講老人要重訓對老人一定要重訓
因為很多人就是一疊一疊就拜拜
是
老人家這連鎖反應很重要
那老人 問題是我還沒老啊各位
我的70歲我有重訓值比較少 好不好
OK
練錯了點 是 是
M1對我說是為了身材才能跟我在一起
你們怎樣
你們怎樣 還是
不需要試好不好
好不好
練重點練小小的,練大大折可不可以?
大大折還四四,你們真的是為我露題來的,你們不是為我腦袋,
好啦就跟大家講,我看不到300的紅海,我買3隻沒有3隻,
你說你買3隻紅海你被套牢,你剛好而已,
三張還是三骨啊 我都不知道
數量要對 單位要對
要深蹲 喔我深蹲
開玩笑深蹲很重要 你知道嗎
男人就是要深蹲 好不好
不多說自己去做 好不好
剛剛竟然有持窮的時候
我不是持窮 我是被你們意淫啊
不好意思 好不好
今天我還帶你一頂頭髮
什麼我頭髮是深蹲 你別擺頭髮
肉體是配習,不可以拿地賽
來我們看一下,腰力
我蝙蝠腳幹了找了這什麼東西,我不知道這梗
你們今天好嗨喔,我頭好暈喔
剛剛講什麼,你們現在都在洗板了你們
大家心習慣很開心耶
你看每天在洗板你知道嗎
木村偷竿在那邊玩,這尾村怎麼辦
臉紅的深蹲舊傳說,深蹲舊地球
深蹲一下好不好,省那你自己開心一點
今天我深蹲可以解開扣子嗎?我解一個好不好
不要鬧了啦
Rorans不要鬧了好不好
來,華班店跟尾川是不是垃圾谷
常常開盤開高走地
我一定想買華班店
我主要是華班店就機器來講有點高
沒有,我那天看起來要噴出去
然後有,華班店很強好不好
我滿看我華班店的
其實我是真的這天是有點想買
我偷我暈了
哎呀 我在想啦好不好
記憶體還是會拉起來的啦
我跟你講這會缺的啦
我去講記憶體跟TVU晶片不一樣
這就缺很久啦好不好
這我講缺就是會缺好不好
然後我們這樣什麼股票還沒講
098A就不管它了好不好
你們要賣就賣 反正我看很遠
然後我們還是要回到重點
我最後就要講一件事
來莫德納的疫苗講一次
莫德納疫苗怎麼樣
發使用AI莫德納疫苗有沒有
選出從II運算法裡面選出什麼?
34個關鍵的圖片圓,可以編碼2A然後製造疫苗,
個人化疫苗你知道那黑身素流,
你去問醫界的人,醫生留言好不好,
你們不要因為參加者則,當者則粉絲是個榮幸好不好,
你們自己說醫界就知道,
這個很難,拜託個人化疫苗,
社務現來10個,我真的看了研究,
然後超過30%還是50%到70、80歲的時候
都有收護腺癌
其實那個收護腺癌是比較
大部分是比較溫和的
比較輕微
就你到老到死
他都伴隨著你
有些癌症這樣子
你知道嗎
收護腺癌也可以救活
哇塞
黑色素瀏也可以
肺癌也是可以
哇台灣肺癌的人數很多
你知道嗎
來
哲學之前你切了些些節
所以這都OK你知道嗎
OK什麼意思
AI真的改變人生了
你們不要開玩笑
你知道嗎?我昨天跟一群律師吃飯
我還說他們認同
我有個律師
因為拖延那些分析師的事情
拖延那些分析師我提告的事情
搞到現在 像幾分
搞到現在 非常了解法院訴訟的事情
我說你們這樣不需要法助了
要不要律師要不然法助
你先試個法律 為什麼
像改條文會東肉西肉
那個就像下象棋一樣
下象棋除非你是棋丸等級的
不然你一定有輸肉的時候
可是連期完都下相期都輸人家
像不是你那個合約第一條跟第五條
如果有一點護士違背
會不會哪一天少寫的你知道嗎
你問他
像不是有什麼陳迅雲不是嗎
哇陳迅雲最近八卦
這個也可以問他
所以那個時候就是趙建民就是可惜
沒有人捐本來
這個又上新聞了我跟你講
問什麼
這有人說趙建民把那個什麼保密條款
離婚的保密條款拿去小感機場發你知道嗎
本身這個就是怎麼樣
本身這個然後說你陳信宇你要賠一億
暗示他
陳信宇說我問我的律師
你連條款本身都不能講
你講的以後就是
保密條款就連保密都不能講
你知道嗎
連保密那種法一億都不能講
你講的你也要賠一億
互相指責對方要賠一億
趙建民本來可以告他一億你知道嗎
那這個就好玩了
這個就要建法律
因為說好說好陳信宇是真的爆料
他可能是要輸這一億
你懂不懂?趙建民如果用Gemma用AI的話
他可能就不會去發這個東西
他說只能說我們要保密條款
我準備提告站這樣就好了
你懂不懂意思嗎?
這樣他就勝算機率很高
他本來就有機會贏了
可是到時候可能要
你要我培議,你要培議
那就沒意思了
雖然用AI,少了法律助理
所以趙建民多優秀
台大一科的多優秀
是不是兩多優秀
少用AI了,你懂不懂?
我想是真的啦
會用AI的人會贏很多人你知道嗎?
可是其實我們那天還在討論
連律師的討論以後能怎麼辦?
很多人會被淘汰
因為一個人像我一樣做事情
很多事情我都不找回合約
我自己做比較快
因為我直接問AI
架構寫合約公司每天要寫很多合約
每天要寫一些合約的內容
那其實找律師還不一定寫得好
因為他會漏你知道嗎?
OK嗎?
來保密就不能說
每一股夜盤想要展怎麼看?
來
紅矮說看不到300真的看不到
你們要諷刺我再也看不到300
那時候我就看不到300,519%增加
那時候台積電我都看不到600,還不是被他笑一陣子
現在誰笑誰?
前陣子2500,是不是OK嗎?
來來,美在時率居高不下
好啦,就這樣子,最後幾分了
50要結束了,今天我們來,我不要講了
管達外尾算,等有量再說
全足股美量人怎麼辦?
是不是那個華星科我覺得可以買
我覺得那個誰
這都是交加集團的
華班店我覺得也不錯
好不好
細金圓
我跟你講中美金跟環球金投資在投買
而且感覺是在養他
感覺要認養
他們應該跟我一樣
已經預期到明年會大缺貨
明年缺貨基金很高
我不敢做百分之百
我們是合格分一師
我是赫德本殷師,股資有賺有賠
可是如果你覺得者者是你認真最優秀的、最幽默
或是你為了肉體,就算他不要為了肉體
你覺得可以把你賺錢的本殷師
換來那些下去,080、060、8080,我會嫁給我賴思緒
不論對我,我會做者者一切一切,遇到前面
量數的極致後就有一個方向
台舊補台股下半年萬計要開始
趕快來一起來跟我賺大錢,我一起努力
你盡我一千努力來幫你大家賺大錢
謝謝各位 拜拜